CBS News contributor ed O'Keefe is a
congressional reporter for the
Washington Post
joins us at the table to discuss IDI
what a day yesterday on the Capitol
everybody was saying listen Jeff Flake
says now is the time enough people need
to stand up do you think it will have an
impact knowing or we keep hearing that
many people feel privately with Jeff
Flake what bob corker and to some degree
what john mccain is are saying out loud
i think the day i'm starting to break a
little bit the fact that you've seen
former president bush last week given
address it didn't use the president's
name but certainly alluded to him John
McCain's been at it for several months
bob Corker has been saying what he's
saying and Jeff Flake is now saying
publicly what he's been saying privately
for more than a year in addition to his
public criticism one in we'll see you
know I think the fact that so many of
them yesterday I mean there were
colleagues of his is sitting in the
seats kind of near tears because they
understand that what's going on right
now is as he said not normal is
seriously eroding the fabric of the
country and I suspect we'll see some
more speak up it's what's interesting to
him Friedman writes today I mean talking
to a letter to McMaster tell me not
sorry to the Secretary of Defense James
Madison I mean you need to lead McMaster
Tillison and Kelly Pompey I was a lost
cause out of CIA in telling trump that
if he does not change his ways you will
all quit on mosques yeah if it comes to
those kinds of people then when were in
real trouble and that is what members of
Congress have been saying we know for a
long time they saw Reince Priebus as an
ally in the White House he's gone now
they look to the three who run national
security and believe that they're
perhaps the last best hope but what is
what is flakes resigning do in terms of
changing the system it allows him to
speak up and potentially it allows him
to vote against some of what the
president would like to see done
remember it's important remember he is
not a moderate main street mainstream
Republican he's an awfully nice guy
good-looking you know whatever but
libertarian staunchly conservative
especially on fiscal matters budget Hawk
he's a budget Hawk he does not like the
idea of deficit spending he wants to
maintain global trade deals all of that
the Natha matters the president don't be
surprised if you see him put up a bigger
fight now perhaps on the tax with Steve
banning and his supporters in the White
House are certainly doing the hula
saying
and he had no chance of winning anyway
so and Steve Bannon his forces are
taking credit for forcing this
retirement do you think they have a
point they in the case of Arizona that
was actually a foot before ban and
really started Kelly Ward ran against
this is the woman who was running
against Jeff Flake in the primary had
done this against John McCain making a
generational argument and an ideological
argument now with President Trump in
office she was making an ideological
argument against Jeff Flake and it was
sticking he was down double digits to
her and probably would have been
underwater in a general election against
a moderate Democratic congresswoman
who's gonna run against who's gonna run
for the Senate seat next year here's a
question we asked senator flake do you
think this will change the president in
any way you saw the tweet this morning
already to suggest no and you certainly
saw the White House reaction yesterday
which said you know these guys are
basically just sore losers yeah there's
no indication yet that that will happen
and I think it's also important to know
flake told you guys there's no grounds
for impeachment there's no reason to use
the 25th amendment but there are reasons
perhaps Republicans and others to speak
up more forcefully against him all right
knatokie thanks so much for joining us
we appreciate it